more than two dozen states are making a
last-ditch effort to block the release
of blueprints for 3d printed guns at
least eight states and the District of
Columbia are suing the Trump
administration for allowing a Texas
company to resume distribution of the
blueprints as early as tomorrow in
addition more than 20 state attorneys
general have asked the State Department
to intervene the company behind the
blueprints argues it is protected by
freedom of speech
Tony Duke opal is at a gun store in
Austin Texas with what's next in the
legal battle Tony good morning good
morning I'm at Central Texas gun works
in Austin and I want to show you
something to help people understand
exactly what is at stake here
this is an ar-15 people can recognize
that this is a computer-controlled
milling machine it allows people to make
that at home no background checks now
this machine and others like it
including 3d printers which make guns
out of plastic require digital
blueprints to work
it's those digital blueprints that gun
safety advocates worry could be
dangerous in the wrong hands the goal
will be to communicate to the court that
we want to shut this down amelie a
lawsuit filed Monday by Democratic
Washington State Attorney General Bob
Ferguson says the release of blueprints
for 3d printed guns on the internet
would make the lethal weapons available
to virtually anyone when it comes
something as basic as Public Safety this
is a giveaway for terrorists eight other
Democratic state attorneys general are
now joining Ferguson suit against the
Trump administration in April the
federal government settled a lawsuit
with the nonprofit defense distributed
allowing the company to publish digital
schematics for 3d printed guns in a
statement to CBS the State Department
says the decision to settle the case was
made in the interest of the security and
foreign policy of the United States I
think almost without exception that
people have a right to to this kind of
data regarding anything
five years ago defense distributed
founder Cody Wilson introduced The
Liberator a single-shot handgun made
almost entirely of 3d printed plastic on
August first blueprint
four guns ranging from The Liberator to
an ar-15 style assault rifle will be
available for download from defense
distributed for free
you cannot regulate the digital material
of guns anymore it's out there the
so-called ghost guns don't have serial
numbers and are therefore untraceable
and require no background checks
that's something Ferguson warns is a
threat to national security and who pays
the cost the public it's outrageous is
it the end of gun control like I think
it is an essential sense there's Cody
Wilson there his supporters believe
these last-minute lawsuits will fail
because computer code which makes these
machines work is it essentially speech
and therefore protected now either way
it may be too late more than a thousand
downloads have already been made of an
ar-15 style 3d printed gun that Cody
posted early and he seems prepared to
fight to keep those files online
tweeting recently we will not be
silenced Norah Tony thanks scary to
think that you could do that it's it's
very scary because it's mean the
argument that it's out there and
uncontrollable is on some level is
convincing and I don't know whatever you
think of the free speech argument I
don't know how you control this well
even those gun owners and those who
respect the rights of gun owners believe
in safety yes and believe in teaching
and that's what worries me about being
able to just print one of these
everybody learns like how to use it
properly should be some oversight hmm in
terms of printing weaponry thank you
Tony